Oh
[Music]
so in nice try news when I strap on it
mm-hmm submitted by hi Jake hey so I
hope you're having a good day that's a
good name is nice also no connection a
little tried to get we're just cops
before an injury but she forgot CCTV was
watching this isn't in American didn't
you know we had to experience something
like that what a leak so at the gym
there was a guy that was always he was
always caught in his cleaning hours
extra and then we stand up to someone
else so we would see if we check the
surveillance cameras and then this
person would be as soon as the gym
clothes he's like you just see the
security footage of this little bit of
this action a little bit of random
working out action at the time boy there
is no jacking off and then finally I
know jack enough action people's asleep
in action and then finally up clean a
little bit time ago and we'll always
clock out like 3-4 hours extra what [ __ ]
700 it's more of that person so I know
something not only fired this is it what
a piece of [ __ ] you think you know
beautiful huh how but Dumbo and when
your dick or maybe that just means
you're gonna have a really clean gym so
you have anything to do there's always
something it's a gym I do it there's
always more germs it's a gym dude yeah
it's a pretty funny film just going to
show you guys the video what this isn't
America watch your [ __ ] start
coordinating a Florida Oh somebody's I
thought it was some other countries it
was an on-the-job injury or was it watch
what happens when the sprinkler head
falls from a South Florida office
ceiling it lands on an employee's desk
missing her but wait for it she gets an
idea looks around and bam time to file
her own head her employer's insurance
company got suspicious and referred the
incident to Florida's division of
investigative angela's detectives
requested the security cam footage
that's [ __ ] hilarious we kind of
don't you the criminal you kind of long
for two seconds to come up with that
here he just went full force
I would never hit myself I love myself
mmm meanwhile none of the typical types
of claim fraud
I could watch over an hour she thinks
you're the crazy thing is that is like
that shows how inherently evil that
person is that means that person had
waited for this moment for a spring
gonna fall down she said because she
look like she's got some beginning
October and efficient a brunette
identified do you want to know her name
Danica Gonzalez you're gonna plug him
laughs so her name is Shayla
Veronica aha white
oh never not brown white middle name if
never white exactly yeah I what
ethnicities you know with the wit was
the last thing that we I genuinely no
more black people who fled she black
exactly Sheena left changed her name it
was probably Blanca or Blanco before why
I know black Veronica's - maybe she's
but no don't be black [ __ ] that that's
white people stuff she let on the
kindest thing she got hit and she went
all a uh-huh that's hilarious
shows how desperate she is in her life
how do you think that fast to be
deceptive usually I actually like kind
of like devise a plan like okay this is
what I'm going to shoot it of course I
think it was a situation where I was
like oh my god that could have fell on
my head oh my god that's me okay my head
but I would have done is it falls right
so far I'm like why not only angled
[ __ ] back to work that's it but what
she's doing she's the girl at the
intersection that sees two cars land and
she goes and gets a side mirror oh [ __ ]
I was also on the car accident and it's
funny cuz I want to hear the audio from
that I hear her boy c'mon out yeah cuz
wish you wish you it Oh sweetie I'm not
sure because doesn't say how long she
worked I know there's very little
information on it women me all the
information I do have is the fact that
they caught this insurance fraud before
she ever got any money so she doesn't
have to pay any restitution or anything
but she did get 18 months of probation
yeah legal probation or work probation I
hope check out I want to find out a
fighter like that oh yeah
cuz I how do you not know their security
cameras at your job like it's not
hitting in a bad criminal eye security
cameras pretty apparent I wonder how
long she second yeah that's what I'm
saying I wonder how low she were they're
like was her second day she never looked
up like I don't get it really the
cameras like right here it is a dude
hole in the camera you know what do you
you didn't see a horse you right now if
you guys would have witnessed this
yourself would you would you have pulled
her out
hell yeah cracking them fuck-ups with a
laughing she was just here there's
laughing do you feel like you dumb [ __ ]
like she prepares to do it yeah like she
saw you there's no way that would happen
but if you were watching the camera
that's done that would be hilarious I
just get on the intercom please don't
hate yourself ma'am that's weird to do
man please don't do that
when I had a shitty car and I kept on
getting into car sense with it I just I
got so mad because it didn't get damaged
enough while you in a new car look okay
I just get t-boned but it was just be
like a fender bender so I hope that
that's what we've been TiVo and that's
when he wanted to be a superhero and
stop the car II know what happened
yesterday yesterday as I was driving
home actually hit a car you did yeah
should be botella
you can tell her or the cops close that
you know our lives are just so fast that
it's just like why are you prepared they
were slow as far as we were I was
driving off to get food for you we
stopped you blew a kiss like that comes
with that double Mexico is I completed
all hop on the freeway so what happened
was we should never do this of course I
was texting while driving how many times
to do that okay extra high why are you
telling but the cool thing was this this
is a cootie so there is no call the cool
thing is you pulled over and you to know
that I'm you know physically I didn't
get caught that's the coolest is why I
love illegal immigrants hours in the car
dragons taking the Porsche right I was
going forward
oh my hero I look up and I'm like this
is gonna be bad he sees me in a Porsche
she's gonna be like this [ __ ]
has money I'm gonna try to take him for
all he's got so I wait for him to pull
over I'm like okay he's not pulling over
one light so why did you hit him how do
young Mazetti was he moving you know how
like stop and go traffic so he stopped
I'm looking down oh man I hit up ah damn
it
wait on the street of the freeway do it
oh go traffic there a lot of damage no
oh but he didn't even get on the car to
check so you know there's not his papers
but I'm like thank God so horrible only
we're not talking the rest of this
[ __ ] episode one you don't even
realize you know he knows I had a what a
car history you know what was the car us
a category like a Nissan Sentra people
don't know sometimes cuz I heat up in
these ovens at soccer
couples it's like I might get deported I
thought it he felt it you guys make eye
contact at all like driving I'm trying
not to I'm trying oh please forget let's
remember you're [ __ ] illegal you
don't got papers you don't want to deal
with this [ __ ] I was just trying about
right you know you don't want to get out
of the car again for the record this is
my child in my child alone has no father
why are you always saying nothing so
funny like you just hear him like making
excuses for you god
Thunderbolt was really uh yeah I didn't
feel anything what if he was afraid what
if you thought he was being hate-crimed
in right there you're an [ __ ]
you're an ass engine I'm not gonna find
him hmm I hired him
you're the small like McSwain thing
you're offending my uncle every Chinese
restaurant has a Mexican cook what are
you talking about cause we [ __ ] cook
bomb yes we're also validating my place
is Barry talking about you're talking
[ __ ]
I am you own a restaurant sure but if I
did the soldiers untilled many horrible
things about any human gig sounds sexy
you're driving right but I mean he can't
get a job he's a horrible person
no no sometimes people realizing I hate
because when I first got my car I was
trying to get on the ramp to the freeway
and so I was right here and then this
cart like the truck kind of camp in
front of me but he didn't see me he was
dragging my car for like a good I don't
know like 10 15 seconds or something and
then I was like what the hell I had to
like honk and you really see me this guy
knew because he got I got the quick eyes
in the rear view you know the bush like
that if I was driving off looking at his
review and I see his eyes and go back
back now I know yeah it turns solo coke
he knows what happened close Oh what if
you one of the drug dealers huh I
learned my lesson thank you guys for not
getting me you didn't learn your [ __ ]
less because you were trying to text
this morning and I was like y'all I'm in
the car
[ __ ] adult I learned my lesson because
your car is not stick shift
what oh my god you're gonna get so much
[ __ ] for this episode yep my next car
I'm going to comment can everyone please
comment what a shitty prison he is but
he needs to know he's in deny you're
gonna go I'm coming here common I
donated to the Red Cross
shitty / you are a Shan I give blood you
gave blood for your own benefit
No yeah hi jeans were delicious give
blood for all the people I paint on the
road ha ha those high seas are amazing
for the high seas all are the animal
you're the worst
circus on everything that you just met
oh just like you seem like the type
reasonable guruship then you can supply
a [ __ ] bag oh I want to fix the [ __ ]
sprinkler mhm yeah right and so on oh
that's a [ __ ] thing is in front of
you're not stupid up at me I was like I
want to get hit by a car - no you don't
gonna be hit by a car but be ok down
tonight can I hit you way in your own
car no we're not savages if I had a
really crappy car it would be nice to
get hit by another car
mmm what the [ __ ] wrong with you I think
about stuff like that and I know with my
look like I'd be paralyzed from the
waist you know what I did have that
curiosity and then it happened to me
where I actually rear-ended someone and
it's exactly horrible person I shut up I
got out of the car okay oh and get out
huh and it's exactly what you think it
would feel like like just a cocaine just
like crushed yeah I've been hit pretty
hard but nothing happened much no I've
hit all you've hit you piece of [ __ ]
what not securement texting that's it
then why yeah I know I was actually
horse you know fellas late for an
appointment
be like [ __ ] you like it all day for an
appointment I was panicking and then
everyone was stopped on this engine
driving up one of our students I was on
this Lane and then I everyone was
stopping here so I'm like [ __ ] that I'm
going to be late so I moved over this
one and then this person slammed on the
brakes and then that's when I grabbed it
on that person you have no [ __ ]
ground right now when I first got my
Jeep this Mexican dude to his truck
he'd be Guatemalan you know he's Mexican
yeah that was those make some stuff on
top of watermelon or Japanese no it was
Mexican
like he backed into my Jeep so when I
just got it and then he just left and I
just like alright that's about it yeah
but that for me is like am I going to
chase this guy down by what is he what
am I gonna take from the guy you know
what I mean I followed him for three
life his things
I want those [ __ ] rakes right now
buddy how do you follow someone with
lights on a freeway I mean there's no
like okay we hit and then we exited and
I followed them for three lights he's
get out isn't he thought you were
chasing him down they go to fun to cook
how's it going guys don't forget to like
the video because if you don't I will
break your [ __ ] legs
thank you so much for the last video
don't forget to click right here or I'll
break your [ __ ] arms click right here
guys